and you know the marlin starter you just
don't know him as a starter it'll be his
first time on the hill to begin a game
anthony bender he has done
i don't know everything for the marlins
thus far out of the bullpen and he's
done it fast
it is very fair well we certainly know
his stuff plays big-time fastball 97-98
miles an hour two-seamer along with a
nasty slider
that one's in the air to center field
moving to his right is starling marte
and he makes the catch that's out number
one they'll look to keep it going
against fernando tatis junior ball and
two strikes
and they'll check down at first and he
went around the strikeout for anthony
bender i'll give you a little side view
tatis looked like he went around bender
and the marlins get the call so a huge
second out south florida's own manny
machado born in hialeah
and a ground ball to birdie gets a good
hop throws across the diamond bender
gets through the first no runs blake
snell on the mound for the friars blake
snell set to make a second start of the
second half making his 18th start
opponents hitting 247 off of blake's now
he's got a cut down on the walks 48
walks this year in 74 innings fewer hits
at 71 and he has struck out 96. the
hostile lead at first 1-1 to starling
martay
and a breaking ball hit on the ground to
short that's he's got one play it's at
first and he makes it as rojas was on
the move so he takes second base easily
and there's one down here in the bottom
of the first inning bring up jesus
aguilar one two pitch coming up here to
aguilar there it is and a swing and a
miss went back to back with a slider
that'll work first strikeout for snell
two down here in the first inning this
is not a replay of the the previous
slider he just repeated his delivery and
went right back there throw it be
aggressive with it two down here in the
bottom of the first inning rojas at
second base and adam duvall standing in
on the right side
and a swing and a miss goes after that
curveball gotta throw him out and they
do back-to-back strikeouts for blake
snell first he gets aguilar then he
comes back to get duvall two strikeouts
done with one without a score from miami
first and third with one out here comes
jerks and profile batting out of the
eight spot
on the ground to first base to second
for one back to first it is not in time
and a runal score and from third comes
hosmer and the padres strike first on
top one to nothing marlins almost pulled
that off and got out of the jam but the
padres pick up a run thanks to the speed
of juricks and profar boy as a hitter
especially one out runners at the
corners you hit this ground ball you
want to beat it out you want to beat
that out so that runs scores if they're
going to challenge here and they do on
the headsets we'll get a look let's
check the empire here on this call safe
off the back and what do we got safe so
the pot ridge do get a run call stands
and a one-nothing padre lead as osmore
scores the run that'll get blake snell
to the dish with his two-game hitting
streak we're hitting the air to left
field brings it over towards the line
and he gets there to make the catch and
andy in it padres get a run two on
nobody out and brings up lewis brenson
swinging a miss and he's able to strike
out brenton there's a third strikeout
for schnell one down in the inning and
another slider why not you get the feel
for it you locate it and you're gonna
get good results there's the release
point there's the spin
and the good tilt on it brought him down
to a knee for the strikeout one out
first and second brings up joe panic
on the ground right side could be two to
second for one on to first it is two
four six three on the dp he needed to
get out of that jam no runs a hit and a
man left works around the lead double by
jorge alfaro two on two down turns up
profile with two outs and runners in
scoring position flared to center and
that's going to get in for a base hit
from second base comes fam here comes
the throw he'll score throws up the
third base line and the padres take a
two-nothing lead jerks and profiles
driven in both padres runs over the
course of this season jerks profile has
done quite well at the plate drawing
some walks putting together some good
at-bats following some pitches off to
get another hack at it and this one he
fights off dumps it into shallow center
and then the race is on for tommy fan
with two outs cracking the bat scoring
easily and adding on top walk by tati
says cronworth has been hit by a pitch
and grounded out to shortstop taking off
his tatis throw down there will be late
stays on the bag tag was on the helmet
it appeared and fernando able to steal
second base i'll tell you what fernando
tatis jr is fun to watch in the batter's
box with the glove and also stealing
bases and if anybody has perfected the
feet first slide and then going into the
splits it's fernando oh don't forget the
hair flip
there you go oh yeah yeah yeah
tag stay on yes oh
i love it god i wish i could do that
highest ops with runners in scoring
position manny machado coming up here
over 1300 in that category let's see
what he can do here one out in the fifth
inning fernando at third base
in the air to left field brenson is
there makes the catch tagging is tatis
the throw will go to short and the
padres will take a three-nothing lead
sac fly for manny machado to pick up an
rbi and the padres have a three-nothing
lead in miami well like frank sinatra
saying nice and easy does it every time
nice and easy swing for manny getting a
breaking ball getting extended and sent
to left field to drive in that run in
steps manny machado one and one the
count
ground ball right at rojas the flip to
panic on to first and a double play
marlins turned four double plays last
night in dc they get their first here
tonight now that's right rojas and panic
certainly should be in rhythm and they
are hard hit
off the bat of machado but right at
rojas one step and
down to a knee quick flip to panic and
an easy double play is a huge part of
last night's victory john bertie up to
the third time he's walked and struck
out
marlon's first run 90 feet away and that
one gets birdie and he's down 15th hit
by pitch
this season from austin adams is by far
and away the most in the majors scary as
birdie tried to turn away from the ball
went down in the heap and fortunately up
quickly that's going to do it for john
bertie slider out of hand you can see
the miss got underneath it this thing
backs up the entire time and you know
what the helmet probably got i don't
know a quarter of the baseball most of
that baseball
because of the way john went down ended
up catching his head clean i think
that's what you've got that that
baseball is what
left the mark on the back of his head
now it's joe panic with two on and one
out
in the left center field that is going
to drop in for a base hit joe panic gets
the marlins on the board rbi single
brings home diaz and the marlins are
within two well
good approach from joe the marlins
continue to hang around it's a slider
it's up didn't get out in front didn't
try to pull it a little bit earlier in
this ball game saw ground ball on the
side ball off the bat of joe joe really
back to right
deliberately pulled his hands in and
tried to go the other way thus rewarded
with an rbi single two outs bases full
for martay
curtis comes in to score marlins are
down a run it's a 3-2 game and the bases
are still loaded two outs in the ninth
inning and sandy leone now bats with two
outs bases empty in the ninth inning
on the ground to first base pro fire's
got it he'll tag the bag padres win mark
melanson comes in as a one two three
ninth inning and the padres down the
miami marlons three to two